ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
wonderful ryan michele
i'm freaking out because you're here i'm
so freaked
i've been like you know you dress for a
date like i've been dressing for i was
like she will do you think she'll like
this oh my god oh my god i'll be your
team please do please do i'm doing
nothing after this what are you doing
let's go um well you are married to like
the most special guy ever sterling brown
he's very
he's very special
now is it true he told me a story about
when you guys like first met
and then you got like back together
is that
what's your side of the story no we did
my husband and i met and we have gotten
back together several times over the
course of like i don't know how many
years there was there was a lot of uh
breakups to makeups so it got to the
point where we both had to be like you
know what we should just try being
adults about this and that worked funny
enough
being a doll big adult we were and
that's actually the thing that he said
that when one of the last time that we
found our way back to each other he said
i think the reason why i've been dating
all of these other girls is because i
keep looking for you and they're not you
exactly and that was the thing that made
me go okay
you can say a little bit more about that
they're not me
say it again a little louder you know
but it was very very sweet and that was
the moment that i was like okay we can
let's talk like adults and i mean you
know it's so interesting because you
grow up so much like
i'm so different than i was a decade ago
five years ago no i know i know and then
it's a matter of how do we learn to grow
together yes i suppose and you did you
figured it out yeah well there there was
a
there's a little secret to my success as
trying to be married in the kids and all
this stuff
and it's a little movie called
irreconcilable differences oh my god i'm
in that really
yes
i play a seven-year-old girl who tries
to divorce her parents i i am i
chapter and verse that movie and i would
and i'm an only child and you were an
only child and i would look at that
movie and i'd be like she's speaking to
me you're like the most incredible child
in that movie you're you're so good and
you're so well behaved and all you want
is your parents to like notice and and i
just remember thinking like i have to be
a better parent like this movie is
teaching me how to be a good parent so
i'm so
[Applause]
but it teaches you that like little kids
are watching and they're not as you know
dumb as they're innocent but they're not
dumb and there's a difference you know
what i mean they're watching everything
and your mom was a disco queen and my
mom in all of this my mother's you know
a disco queen and she had a song um like
that was on the top 100 for like 10
weeks in a row they just told me today i
didn't even know that i didn't even yeah
ten weeks in a row isn't that crazy that
would be crazy what was it like growing
up with a disco mama because i love
disco i love disco too maybe that's why
i love disco cause i was it's like it's
truly in my blood it's in my bones as a
matter of fact we lived across the
street from studio 54. oh my god i used
to go to studio 54 when i was like 7
through 10. i know i know i have used
that argument to get my mom to take me
to studio i was like drew barrymore is
there and she's like well where do you
bury more's parents and i was like oh
okay never mind and she was also in a um
a broadway show called lena horne show
the lady in her music ah of course and
yeah and so i grew up backstage on
broadway i mean that's all i i knew and
so backstage is in the backstage mic and
i would sing on the backstage and i was
like this high and it was like you know
and i would so that's all i knew and i i
think
i think the good part is that i never
attached myself to the glamour of what
it was like to be on stage i always
attach myself to the glamour at what it
was like to be off stage you know like
oh i did too
i did too right you know and like the
idea that you are a part of a company
that you're responsible to these other
people you're responsible to these other
women that and i've seen women like give
each other bras and chicken cut you know
the little things you put in your and
like and and and um fix each other's
girl your your your you know your
eyelashes falling down thank you girl
like i saw that yeah part of it and
that's what i fell in love with the
community the camaraderie and the work i
knew that it was work i knew that you
had to stretch and
and warm up before you got on that stage
and so that's the part that i think i
remember the most and not the glamour of
it i love that that's such a good
fundamental for life
[Music]